[laughter]
- Hey, hey, hey!
If I knew you guys
were in town--
- Get out of here!
- --we would have been gone.
How you doing, bro?
- Yeah!
[music playing]
This was the first post-war
American sports car.
It came out in 1951.
The Chevy Corvette
came out in 1953.
Think about the guy that bought
this car back in the day.
They were a driver.
It was extremely expensive.
They knew what they
were getting into.
Stitch!
- Hey!
[laughter]
Tell me what you did!
The master herself.
Oh, it's got power windows?
It does.
Push the button.
STITCH: Woo!
MIKE WOLFE: Are you kidding me?
STITCH: Slick, huh?
I like that.
We literally had
to fix everything.
Every time I went to work on
it, something was rusted shut.
I had to wrestle this
car to the ground
and put my boot on its neck.
Ooh, baby, I love
when you talk that way.
This was one of
those projects that we
were pretty stoked to get.
But we had our moments
where we just really
weren't that excited about it.
[laughter]
And I'll tell you why--
Two years, man.
Well, here's
the reason why, is
because in a normal restoration,
you bring it back new.
This one, we're
trying to keep it
like it just came
out of the barn--
MIKE WOLFE: You did it!
- --not all shiny new.
So I mean, we just
threw stuff at it
until we liked what we saw.
You guys nailed it, man.
We tried different [inaudible]
different techniques.
You absolutely nailed it.
Yeah, I mean, he
welded some panels
in where fresh metal
had to be patinaed
to make it look like it is.
MIKE WOLFE: This car has
been like a wild animal
that needed to be tamed.
From the moment we
decided to pull it out--
FRANK FRITZ: Oh, oh, oh, ho!
MIKE WOLFE: Whoa!
This thing fought
me tooth and nail.
It made me scratch in the mud,
in the rain to resurrect it.
But I had the easy
part of this job.
Crafty B and Stitch are
the ones who've been living
with this thing for two years.
We had a little
problem with the motor,
and it had to come back out.
We had some push rod issues.
Something that happened at
the engine machine shop.
Nobody caught it, it
wasn't a big deal.
But they fixed it.
- Oh my gosh.
CRAFTY B: And we put
her back in and--
FRANK FRITZ: That's
a lot of engine.
The coolest thing
about this car
was totally the
motor, and the fact
that somebody pulled
the original motor out
and put a Cadillac motor in it.
That's the moment for me.
MIKE WOLFE: That is killer.
When Nash was thinking
about building the car,
he wanted a Caddy engine in it.
Now we're bringing
all that back to life.
And Crafty B was
the guy that did it.
We actually buffed
the paint, you know?
And I think it buffed
out pretty good.
And then we blended in some
different-- like, actually wood
stain.
And then we cleared it.
We fixed all the rust.
Can I touch it?
Sure.
You know you wanted
gray, so I gave you gray.
I love gray!
I wanted to put a little
plaid influence in there.
I wanted to keep the style
like the original seat
was as far as the pattern.
I was trying to get
into the brain of Mike,
of what is your passion?
What are you thinking?
But also trying to honor the
original interior of this car.
So I added a little bit
of European influence.
It's suited to the
car, the age, the year.
It's impressive.
And then I thought,
well, a red carpet
bounded it in the gray.
See, I wanted to
turn you loose on this.
I wanted you to do
whatever you wanted to do.
I entrusted you.
It's incredible, really.
[laughter]
I mean, it's beautiful.
STITCH: Aw, thanks.
Awesome.
It is.
I mean, it's a work of art.
When you look at the
exterior of the car,
and you can see it's
worn and it's weathered
and it tells a story, you don't
want to open the door and go--
wow, what happened
to the interior?
You want it to connect.
She did that.
She did the right colors.
I mean, the choices that she
made are absolutely perfect.
Frank, check the key, man.
FRANK FRITZ: Oh, that's cool.
[laughter]
That's a Crafty B custom.
Start her up, big boy.
FRANK FRITZ: Let's
hear this thing purr.
STITCH: Woo!
[laughter]
FRANK FRITZ: Sounds good!
MIKE WOLFE: The car
exceeded every expectation.
This steering
wheel is huge, man.
It's like a school
bus steering wheel.
This was an evolution
that had to happen.
I got to drive it, man.
- Brakes are good, right?
- Sorry, man.
Hey, wait for me.
MIKE WOLFE: Crafty
B and Stitch lived
with this thing for two years.
And they never lost sight of
what my vision was, and they
carried it through, man.
It's bad to the bone.
Get out of here!
[laughter]
MIKE WOLFE: I've sat
in this car a few times
and imagined what it was like
to drive it, how it would sound,
how it would handle.
It's been a journey.
But now after driving
it and feeling it,
I know I made the right
decision on the shop I chose,
and just flat out doing it.
Because now, man, it's
got lots of life and lots
of miles ahead of it.